and so I think what the psychedelics and
Ayahuasca do is it's a it's a sort of
controlled therapeutic psychosis
you're going to go in and you're
definitely going to be out of control
and we're going to walk you through you
the throwing up is part of it you know
everybody throws up and what's happening
is your mind is
deconfiguring because it wasn't working
the way it's working
and I use a metaphor because I'm trying
to create
something called guaranteed to blow your
mind how
Ayahuasca works and the idea is if you
think of our mind when we're born is a
rubric's cube and think of it being in
the wrapper and it's pristine and then
life messes it up and we solve it so it
looks like it's in the wrapper
but as life gets complicated the way it
looks in the wrap or doesn't work
anymore
you know life on the outside is
different than life inside a womb and if
you keep trying to solve it for how it
is in the wrapper it's not working
anymore
and so I think what Ayahuasca and
psychedelics do is they scramble up that
rubric's Cube
but when they saw that it's a different
design than it was in the wrapper
and it's the design that you can lean
into
in your life
is this making any sense to you
I think so I've done quite a few
psychedelics I'm not entirely sure how
to think about psychedelics like I
almost think about them as
connecting you to a spiritual level
absolutely like yeah they're pretty
they're pretty wild and they can be
extremely helpful for
um
trauma if you're ready to kind of delve
into it right if you're if you're get if
you get to the headspace where you're
like okay okay for instance when I was
going through that whole thing and in
really bad shape
um after I figured diet out and then
went off with medications and then just
waited to get better
um
I didn't do psychedelics for a number of
years because I was like I cannot adding
that into the mix right now like I that
could go down a really negative route
and yeah you don't want to have like I
mean some people have bad trips and then
they end up better afterwards like even
if it was a negative experience but I at
that point I was like with especially
with SSRI withdrawals like I can't risk
it it's too scary
um and it wasn't until I was in a better
space I actually felt better I'm not
saying this works for everyone but I
felt like stable enough and I was like
okay there's some trauma really and
there's some parts of myself that I
might be hiding that I really need to
sort out because you can like manipulate
yourself in all sorts of ways and like
hide little parts of yourself
away so you don't see them and I was
like I want to make sure everything's
out in the open
and I did a number of pretty heavy-dose
mushroom trips and it was incredibly
beneficial to me I think like I don't
think there was any negative downside
um and I think I was able to sort
through some
problems that would have stayed hidden
for a long time
psychedelics are really wild I think
that they they definitely need to be
used in the therapeutic setting
tell me if this fits your trip because
I've been trying to uh explain it to
people in a way so that you there may be
a way to do it without the mushrooms but
can can you relate to this that you you
took them you were you know and I'm more
of a mental healthy less fragile state
than you've been before so you knew that
and what happened is uh in the middle of
it your mind as you know it it's almost
like it it uh decoupled the things that
you believed uh that you you were
adamant about you weren't so adamant
about but it was okay and things just
started being loose uh and But You Were
Somehow okay because you were mentally
healthy enough to not go off the deep
end and never come back and what happens
is
um uh they were they were they were
loose but then when they came back
together again
here's the metaphor I remember a someone
I know came in uh and and she said this
is what psychedelics did for me she said
psychedelics worked like a plumber
and I said what do you mean
and she said
my mind is like Plumbing
that works but it doesn't flow it's like
my mind is jammed together and I make it
through life but it doesn't flow and
psychedelics rip out the plumbing
uh and then the plumbing gets
reassembled organically
from a place that's more organically
cohesive inside yourself
and when you come out
the water flows
but but before the trip uh if you
haven't had psychotic breaks and you
weren't thrown in hospitals uh it's like
your mind is Plumbing but it just it
just doesn't work it creaks it's and and
maybe it was assembled because of
childhood trauma or who knows what or
disbelief in authority figures but the
the psychedelics Rooks up the plumbing
and then reassembles it in a natural way
and you can just exhale and feel like
life's going to be okay without having
to make sure that you make it okay yeah
okay I like that I think I agree I agree
with most of that I definitely agree
with the feeling that it gives you
afterwards that you don't have to
control everything that things are just
going to work out like it really does uh
it really does leave you with a sense of
I don't have to control everything and
almost like God's will but psychedelics
so I I definitely had had that and then
for reorganizing
yeah I mean I've like I said I've had
really positive experiences with it like
for me I they made me at that time they
made me more loving
so I had more empathy towards other
people so there were people that I was
like this person's kind of annoying
right because there are people that are
like you don't get along with very well
like that person's kind of annoying or I
don't like that person that and it's not
like I was like actively mean but I had
one experience where
I saw every relationship in my entire
life and how I was contributing
negatively to each of those
relationships
I was like oh
I'm doing that like I'm contributing
negatively into the world that way
and it wasn't even judgmental like
that's the that was the interesting
thing it wasn't you're a bad person for
doing for acting that way it was more
kind it was like here's how you're
acting badly towards other people
um that's wrong
and then I was just like well I'll just
stop then
and so it was just like pretty simple it
was like I didn't know that I feel
really bad that I was contributing
negatively to some of these
relationships and I'll stop now and I'm
sorry and then it was you know
forgiveness and they're they're just
they're crazy